this is the programming throwdown episode number one all right that sounds good we should keep that i like that all right so why don't you introduce yourself? All right. My name is Jason Gauci and I'm a software engineer, but by day by night work on emulators work on like main with the main team and Mess the mess emulator and different open source projects and just overall general hacker. All right, that's pretty good I wouldn't what about you? What are you up to? It's pretty modest sounding, but I know you do a lot more than that. Mine pales by comparison, man. I'm Patrick Wheeler, and coder by day, and general do house chores around the house at night.
这是Programming Throwdown的第一期节目，好的，听起来不错，我们应该保留这个，我喜欢这个，那么你为什么不自我介绍一下呢？好的。我叫Jason Gauci，我是一名软件工程师，白天工作，晚上研究模拟器，比如和MAME团队以及MESS模拟器合作，还有各种开源项目，总的来说就是一个普通的黑客。好的，那很不错，你呢？你在忙什么？听起来很谦虚，但我知道你做的远不止这些。相比之下，我做的简直微不足道。我是Patrick Wheeler，白天写代码，晚上在家里做家务。
Sleeper by night. Yeah. I was digging in the dark tonight trying to fix my sprinklers so oh man how did that go it worked i i finally got it done in the pitch black spraying myself with reclaimed water so oh nice but it's all fixed now oh man i raked my yard and it's uh there's nothing underneath like the rake i just kept raking when i was done there's just dirt so i'm in pretty coding is way more fun than digging in the dirt yeah definitely agreed uh good stuff all right well let's go ahead and get get started here so you have any news for us jason yeah let's see so yeah i guess we have this news
晚上睡觉。是啊。我今晚在黑暗中挖掘，试图修理我的喷水装置，天哪，进展如何？成功了，我终于在漆黑中完成了，还被再生水喷了一身，哦，不错，但现在都修好了，天哪，我耙了我的院子，下面什么都没有，就像耙子一样，我只是不停地耙，耙完之后只有泥土，所以我，编码比在泥土里挖掘有趣多了，是的，绝对同意，好东西，好了，让我们开始吧，你有什么新闻要告诉我们吗，Jason？是的，让我们看看，我想我们有这个新闻。
about this ps3 um hacker guy getting back at sony and sony going back and forth with him. George Hotz, GeoHot is his internet pseudonym. And he's one of a group, I guess he's teaming up with Failoverflow, which is another hacker group. And together they were able to hack the PS3. And this is pretty cool for people who want to sort of run homebrew software, whether it's emulators or just nice little apps you want to just take advantage of the ps3 hardware in a way that uh you know no one else has really thought of um this gives you that that opportunity i think it's really
关于这个PS3黑客家伙反击索尼，以及索尼和他之间的来回较量。George Hotz，GeoHot是他的互联网化名。他是其中一员，我想他正在和Failoverflow合作，这是另一个黑客组织。他们一起成功破解了PS3。对于那些想要运行自制软件的人来说，这非常酷，无论是模拟器还是你只想以一种没人真正想到的方式利用PS3硬件的小应用程序，这给了你这个机会，我认为这真的
interesting yeah i saw a little bit about that the way he did it uh he's like he's able to figure out the private key for the that son Sony was using to sign its executables? Yeah, so the key is all based on this random number generator. But they found out, diving through the assembly code, that the random number generator was just returning six. So that's a random. Yeah, so totally the encryption completely falls apart when the RNG is just returning 6 the whole time.
很有趣，是的，我看到了一点关于他怎么做到的，他能够找出索尼用来签署其可执行文件的私钥？是的，所以这个密钥完全基于这个随机数生成器。但他们发现，在深入研究汇编代码时，随机数生成器只是返回6。所以那是一个随机数。是的，所以当RNG一直返回6时，加密完全崩溃了。
And between figuring that out and some other hacks in the hardware, they were able to completely unlock the PS3. They were able to get to the point where now they can write, or even you at home can write signed apps for the PS3. And the PS3 hardware thinks that you're a professional developer even though you're some kid in your basement. So that must make Sony pretty scared, right? No control of their platform now. Yeah, I mean, Sony's lost that DRM that they were really trying to hold on to.
在弄清楚这一点以及硬件中的其他一些黑客手段之后，他们能够完全解锁PS3。他们能够达到现在可以编写，甚至你在家里也可以为PS3编写签名应用程序的地步。PS3硬件认为你是一名专业开发人员，即使你只是地下室里的一个孩子。所以这一定让索尼很害怕，对吧？现在对他们的平台没有控制权了。是的，我的意思是，索尼失去了他们一直试图坚持的DRM。
And they'd prided themselves on being the only console that hadn't been hacked. So yeah, they're going and suing George Hotzz and they're also trying to shut down his website it's gone so far they actually sued or they actually commandeered the ip addresses of anyone who's been to his website and the username of of anyone who's uh seen his youtube video so i mean this is really starting to get into personal privacy that seems ridiculous yeah i can't imagine that you know they can get away with stuff like that yeah visiting a website is now a crime i don't yeah yeah i mean it's something straight out of 1984 right they're gonna start knocking on your door i'm not a lawyer but that didn't sound very
他们一直以自己是唯一没有被破解的游戏机而自豪。所以是的，他们去起诉George Hotz，他们也试图关闭他的网站，事情已经发展到他们实际上起诉或实际上征用了任何访问过他网站的人的IP地址，以及任何看过他YouTube视频的人的用户名，所以我的意思是这真的开始涉及个人隐私了，这看起来很荒谬，是的，我无法想象他们能逃脱这种事情，是的，访问一个网站现在成了犯罪，我不，是的，我的意思是这简直是直接出自《1984》，对吧？他们要开始敲你的门了，我不是律师，但这听起来不太
good precedence to say. No, definitely. I just hope that they can appeal that and then it can go further on in the courts and everything. Is it too late, though? They already got all the IP addresses? I mean, once you have that information, I guess the ISPs have to comply so they can figure out who those IP addresses really are. Yeah, I don't know like if you know if you if you can appeal something like that i'm assuming you can do it before they get the ip addresses oh that's true they probably the judge orders you know whoever to turn over the ip address but they don't do it immediately
好的先例。不，绝对不是。我只是希望他们能上诉，然后它可以在法庭上进一步发展。但现在太晚了吗？他们已经得到了所有的IP地址？我的意思是，一旦你有了这些信息，我想ISP必须遵守，这样他们就能弄清楚这些IP地址到底是谁。是的，我不知道如果你能对这样的事情上诉，我假设你可以在他们得到IP地址之前这样做，哦，那是真的，法官可能会命令某人交出IP地址，但他们不会立即这样做。
they probably have time to do it yeah exactly there's this awesome video uh let me see if i can find it here these fail overflow guys going in a like explicit detail on what they uh you know how they pulled off this hack and everything is this a watch at your own peril video yeah this is the kind of video that if you watch you might end up um as part of some court case so uh let's put that disclaimer out there you might need to opt out next time you go to the airport if you watch this video yeah that's right yeah they might take naked pictures of you if you if you watch this video but yeah we'll put it on the blog uh link to it with a disclaimer okay all right sounds good what about you you got any news today oh man so i saw today that nokia is gonna you know try to sell
他们可能有时间去做，是的，确实，有一个很棒的视频，让我看看能不能找到它，这些Failoverflow的家伙非常详细地介绍了他们是如何完成这个黑客攻击的，这是一个“后果自负”的视频吗？是的，这是那种如果你看了可能会最终成为法庭案件一部分的视频，所以让我们发出那个免责声明，如果你看了这个视频，下次你去机场时可能需要选择退出，是的，没错，如果你看了这个视频，他们可能会拍你的裸照，但我们会把它放在博客上，并附上免责声明，好的，听起来不错，你呢？你今天有什么新闻吗？天哪，我今天看到诺基亚要尝试出售
off or relicense their qt and um i guess this is as part of them switching from their own os the symbian os i guess to windows 7 or at least have that emphasis so as part of that i guess they're trying to divest the qt stuff yeah i mean it makes sense nokia's kind of in trouble right because they yeah uh they were doing so good you know they had such a huge market share originally because they didn't they were doing so good you know they had such a huge market share originally because they didn't have any competition like once the smartphones started coming out they're just really in trouble well this is interesting to me uh you know from a technical standpoint from the market i guess not from the technical standpoint from the market standpoint
或重新授权他们的Qt，我想这是他们从自己的操作系统Symbian OS转向Windows 7的一部分，或者至少有这种重点，所以作为其中的一部分，我想他们正试图剥离Qt的东西。是的，我的意思是这很有道理，诺基亚有点麻烦，对吧？因为他们，是的，他们做得很好，你知道他们最初有如此巨大的市场份额，因为他们没有竞争，一旦智能手机开始出现，他们就真的有麻烦了。好吧，这对我来说很有趣，你知道，从技术角度来看，从市场，我想不是从技术角度，而是从市场角度。
though that it's my understanding nok has a huge market share overseas. I know some people from Africa, and they were saying all the phones there are Nokia. And they're mostly the, what do they call them, feature phones, right? Not smartphones. So I guess it's a matter of pride for Nokia to say they have the best smartphone or a great smartphone. But it seems like you can make a pretty good living off of you know dominating the non smartphone market which at this point is still bigger than the smartphone market yeah definitely i think also another uh direction another avenue that nokia is trying to get into is the trying to
虽然据我了解，诺基亚在海外有巨大的市场份额。我认识一些来自非洲的人，他们说那里的手机都是诺基亚。而且它们大多是所谓的“功能手机”，对吧？不是智能手机。所以我认为诺基亚说他们拥有最好的智能手机或伟大的智能手机是一个自尊心的问题。但看起来你可以靠主导非智能手机市场过上相当不错的生活，而这一点目前仍然比智能手机市场大，是的，绝对，我认为诺基亚试图进入的另一个方向是试图
cut into blackberry's market a little bit they've been teaming with microsoft yeah microsoft's really the only person out there who can compete with BlackBerry on the enterprise level, you know? I mean, no one can sync with Outlook like Microsoft, you know what I mean? I would hope. So, yeah, maybe not. At least Microsoft might be able to do it. Yeah, potential is there. So, if they team up, you know, they might be able to edge BlackBerry out, which is just another competitor for BlackBerry.'s i think in some trouble i think competition's good you know drives innovation at some level so yeah it's true there's competition on the on the you know i guess the consumer side with with the iphone and the versus the android and so but
稍微切入黑莓的市场，他们一直在与微软合作，是的，微软真的是唯一能在企业层面与黑莓竞争的人，你知道吗？我的意思是，没有人能像微软那样与Outlook同步，你知道我的意思吗？我希望如此。所以，也许不是。至少微软可能能够做到。是的，潜力是有的。所以，如果他们合作，他们可能能够挤掉黑莓，这只是黑莓的另一个竞争对手。我认为黑莓遇到了一些麻烦，我认为竞争是好的，你知道，在某种程度上推动创新，所以是的，这是真的，在消费者方面，iPhone与Android之间存在竞争，但是
really blackberry's sort of in its own world, and corporations don't really have a choice right now. So on that note, Friday, iPad 2 is coming out. Are you going to be in line? Oh, yeah. I'm thinking about it, but I'm just not sure. The Zune looks really good. It's kind of pricey, though. In the end, most users out there you know don't need all that uh all that memory you know all that uh um ram uh what does it use does it use like flash yeah okay yeah most people don't need that much flash um i sure i i sure don't i mean my plan would be to put uh comics on there and i could put just you know pretty much every every i have every x-men comic and it's only like four gig so uh and i don't need all that on the pad so the zoom's
黑莓真的处于自己的世界中，企业现在真的没有选择。说到这里，周五，iPad 2就要出来了。你会去排队吗？哦，是的。我在考虑，但我不太确定。Zune看起来真的很不错。虽然有点贵。最后，大多数用户不需要所有那些内存，你知道所有那些RAM，它用的是什么？它用的是闪存吗？是的，好的，大多数人不需要那么多闪存，我肯定不需要，我的计划是把漫画放在上面，我可以放几乎每一本X战警漫画，它只有4G左右，所以我不需要在平板电脑上放那么多，所以Zune
looking pretty good but at that price point i don't know i think i'm gonna have to stick with the ipad too might be in line when it comes out yeah i think uh i might i'm probably gonna pass for now but i think my dad's gonna get one so that should be oh really yeah my brother maybe too as well so if they have them and are playing with them I'll probably get envy and might show up with one shortly after nice did either of them have a mac like a macbook pro no actually interesting enough nobody in my family has uh any macbooks or mac computers we do all almost all now have iphones though oh okay What about iPods? Did you guys jump on the iPod thing? No, no.
看起来很不错，但以那个价格点，我不知道，我想我还是得坚持用iPad 2，它出来时我可能会去排队，是的，我想我可能会暂时跳过，但我认为我爸爸会买一个，所以那应该，哦真的吗？是的，我弟弟可能也会买，所以如果他们有并且在玩，我可能会嫉妒，不久之后可能会出现一个，不错，他们中有人有Mac，比如MacBook Pro吗？没有，事实上很有趣，我家里没有人有任何MacBook或Mac电脑，不过我们几乎所有人现在都有iPhone，哦好的，iPod呢？你们赶上iPod潮流了吗？没有，没有。
I had no interest in getting iPods. Really? Yeah. I mean, the iPod Touch was really nice, but by the time I was interested enough to do that, I had an iPhone. Yeah, the iPod Touch came out a little bit too late. I think it actually, didn't it come out after the iPhone? Or maybe like right around the same time? It seems like it did,
我对买iPod没有兴趣。真的吗？是的。我的意思是，iPod Touch真的很不错，但当我感兴趣的时候，我已经有iPhone了。是的，iPod Touch出来得有点太晚了。我想它实际上，它不是在iPhone之后出来的吗？或者可能就在同一时间？看起来确实是这样，
yeah. Yeah. So, but yeah, before that, I that i just had generic whatever you know sansa mp3 player you know it wasn't uh it wasn't an apple product so your dad isn't going to go for the zoom i guess no not the zoom i don't know oh zoom yeah yeah i thought you were saying zoom and i was just mishearing you but okay yeah we're saying saying Zoom, which is the Microsoft MP3 player. Oh, is that what that is? Now all our listeners are completely confused. Yeah, everybody is just, oh, it's all over the place. You can send emails care of Jason for
是的。是的。所以，但在那之前，我只是有普通的Sansa MP3播放器，你知道它不是苹果产品，所以你爸爸不会去买Zune，我想，不，不是Zune，我不知道，哦Zune，是的，我以为你在说Zoom，我只是听错了，但好的，是的，我们在说Zune，也就是微软的MP3播放器。哦，那是那个东西吗？现在我们所有的听众都完全困惑了。是的，每个人都，哦，到处都是。你可以把电子邮件发给Jason，关于
confusion. Yeah, so that's a good point. If you want to write hate mail, write it to P Wheeler. Actually, you can send email. We have our email address programmingthrowdown at gmail.com they can that's right yeah we're both we're both reading that so yeah um definitely you know send us your comments give us your feedback tell us what languages you want um because we will learn
困惑。是的，所以这是一个很好的观点。如果你想写仇恨邮件，写给P Wheeler。其实你可以发邮件。我们有我们的电子邮件地址programmingthrowdown@gmail.com，他们可以，那是对的，是的，我们都在读那个，所以是的，一定要给我们发评论，给我们反馈，告诉我们你想要什么语言，因为我们会学习
just about anything or at least oh we should try to learn anything well okay hang on hang on one more one more news item i had uh facebook bot beluga and this is not terribly interesting in itself beluga is a group messaging app i guess that basically you send text messages to a beluga number and the beluga re-sends them out to people in your group so it's a way like if you know you and a group of friends go to a theme park you can all keep in touch with each other over text messages and not have to pay to send it to four people, just to one number,
几乎任何东西，或者至少，哦，我们应该尝试学习任何东西，好吧，等等，再来一个新闻项目，我有Facebook收购Beluga，这本身并不是特别有趣，Beluga是一个群组消息应用程序，我想你基本上发送短信到一个Beluga号码，然后Beluga把它们重新发送给群组里的人，所以这是一种方式，比如如果你和你的一群朋友去主题公园，你们都可以通过短信保持联系，而不必付钱给四个人发送，只需发送到一个号码，
and then that number will redistribute to everybody. Oh, interesting. So that's kind of interesting. And there's a couple other applications doing something similar. But then I saw some analysis where people are saying that they think Facebook's going to make a run at the SMS itself by every phone now having a Facebook application. If you can send SMS from within Facebook, that'll be data, not text messaging.
然后那个号码会重新分发给每个人。哦，有趣。所以这很有趣。还有其他几个应用程序在做类似的事情。但我看到一些分析，人们说他们认为Facebook会通过现在每部手机都有Facebook应用程序来冲击短信本身。如果你能从Facebook内部发送短信，那将是数据，而不是短信。
And a lot of people will be happy to get rid of those expensive text messaging plans. Oh, that is so good. That is fantastic news because SMS is just ridiculous. They're just making a killing off that. Yeah. So that was the last bit of news I had. Okay. So now on to what you were talking about. So what is the purpose of this podcast, Jason?
很多人会很高兴摆脱那些昂贵的短信套餐。哦，那太好了。这是个好消息，因为短信简直太荒谬了。他们只是靠那个赚大钱。是的。所以这是我有的最后一条新闻。好的。那么现在谈谈你刚才说的。那么这个播客的目的是什么，Jason？
Let me tell us. All right. Let's take a shot at this. So basically what we want to do is throw down a new language every show. In this case, we're looking at making a show every couple weeks. And what we want to do is just take on a new language. We'll spend a couple of weeks beforehand learning it ourselves, and then we'll spend a couple weeks after continuing what we've talked about and advancing on that. And the goal is just to learn new
让我告诉我们。好的。让我们试一试。所以基本上我们想做的是每期节目都推出一种新语言。在这种情况下，我们打算每隔几周做一期节目。我们想做的是学习一种新语言。我们会提前几周自己学习，然后我们会在之后花几周时间继续我们谈论的内容，并在此基础上深入。目标就是学习新的
languages all the time, find out what languages are appropriate for what tasks what are the pros and cons all that good stuff and to just share that knowledge with you guys out there and to also uh you know give you guys some uh more tools for the toolbox when you guys are out there uh you know doing engineering and coding things up yeah tools for the toolbox that's always like to think about it that way. Yeah, yeah, definitely. Right tool for the right job. Yeah, I mean, you know, nowadays,
语言，找出什么语言适合什么任务，优缺点是什么，所有这些好东西，并与你们分享这些知识，也给你们提供一些工具箱里的工具，当你们在外面做工程和编码时，是的，工具箱里的工具，我总是喜欢这样想。是的，是的，绝对。合适的工具做合适的工作。是的，我的意思是，如今，
languages have come so far and there are some languages that are so high level and so efficient, such as, you know, Java and Python. And there are other languages that have been extremely optimized with, you know, SSE and different compiler tools. So namely C and C++, that you just have a wide array of opportunity as a programmer.
语言已经发展了很远，有一些语言非常高级且高效，比如Java和Python。还有其他语言通过SSE和不同的编译器工具进行了极大的优化，即C和C++，你作为程序员有广泛的机会。
Yeah, yeah, that's true. So what languages right now, before we embark on this journey, what languages would you call yourself qualified to program in? My favorite language has always been C++. That's what they taught us in school, you know, in ninth grade or whatever. So I've been kind of sticking to that. But I'm also pretty familiar with C, like Java. I like Python a lot. Getting into, I did a little bit of Lisp, and so I'm starting to get into Scheme a little bit just to understand it.
是的，是的，那是真的。那么在踏上这段旅程之前，你会称自己有资格用什么语言编程？我最喜欢的语言一直是C++。那是他们在学校教我们的，你知道，在九年级什么的。所以我一直坚持用那个。但我对C也很熟悉，比如Java。我非常喜欢Python。开始接触，我做了一点Lisp，所以我开始接触Scheme，只是为了理解它。
But yeah, I'd say those are my favorites. What about you? Yeah, mine are pretty similar. I actually started off learning, I guess, C++ in high school and college did Java. There's some interesting stuff there, especially since it hasn't been that long since I've been out of school. But Java's come kind of far even in just that little time as far as fixing a lot of the complaints about slowness. That's been interesting. Yeah, definitely. Also do a little bit of Python.
但是的，我会说那些是我最喜欢的。你呢？是的，我的也差不多。我实际上是从高中开始学习C++的，大学里学了Java。那里有一些有趣的东西，特别是自从我离开学校没多久以来。但即使在那么短的时间内，Java在修复很多关于缓慢的抱怨方面也走得很远。这很有趣。是的，绝对。也做了一点Python。
Done some kind of crazy stuff in, I guess, what is that, LabVIEW and Visual Basic here and there. A little bit of C Sharp. Oh, nice. And did a little iPhone programming. So that'd be Objective-C. Yep. So that's pretty much it. But mostly, you know, I'd say 90% of my stuff's been in you know cc plus plus yeah definitely i mean those are you know as a
做了一些疯狂的事情，我想，那是什么，LabVIEW和Visual Basic，这里一点那里一点。一点C#。哦，不错。还做了一点iPhone编程。所以那是Objective-C。是的。所以基本上就是这样。但大多数情况下，你知道，我会说我90%的东西都是用C/C++做的，是的，绝对，我的意思是那些是，你知道，作为一个
programmer out there if you're uh you're a kid starting to get into programming those are going to be your core languages that you'll always have to keep you know coming back to yeah i mean i think and in some places i guess people tell me you, it hasn't been my experience yet, but people tell me that there's places where Java is, you know, the de facto standard. But I think learning C or C++ or Java, you can transition back and forth with a little bit of training, but not too much. The concepts are pretty similar. Yeah, yeah, definitely. And then there are some languages like Go and Erlang, you know, and Lisp and Prolog, which are just way off the charts. And you really have to change the way you think and change your paradigm to get your hands around those languages.
程序员，如果你是一个刚开始接触编程的孩子，那些将是你必须一直回来的核心语言，是的，我的意思是，我想在某些地方，人们告诉我，虽然我还没有这种经历，但人们告诉我，有些地方Java是事实上的标准。但我认为学习C或C++或Java，你可以通过一点点培训来回转换，但不需要太多。概念非常相似。是的，是的，绝对。然后还有一些语言，比如Go和Erlang，你知道，还有Lisp和Prolog，它们完全超出了图表。你真的必须改变你的思维方式和范式才能掌握这些语言。
Yeah, yeah. I mean, I had a conversation about this with somebody at work talking about that. I had been doing C++ for a little while and really liked some of the, you know, object-oriented stuff that we were doing in there. And then had to write some C code for a very low-level processor. And was able to take a lot of this stuff I learned out of C++ and use it in C. Even without, you know, just doing classes, the stuff that you learn is applicable. And I try to do the same with, know Python or you know hopefully as part of this getting into you know like Haskell OCaml like you talked about you know Lisp Scheme whatever
是的，是的。我的意思是，我和工作中的某个人谈过这个，谈论那个。我做了一段时间的C++，真的很喜欢我们在里面做的一些面向对象的东西。然后不得不为一个非常底层的处理器写一些C代码。并且能够把我从C++中学到的很多东西应用到C中。即使没有，你知道，只是做类，你学到的东西也是适用的。我尝试用Python做同样的事情，或者希望作为这的一部分，接触到像Haskell、OCaml，就像你谈到的，你知道，Lisp、Scheme，无论什么
those kind of languages and not even just writing code in them but taking the lessons learned the way of thinking and applying that to my everyday coding yeah definitely it always seems like every language has one or two things that it can teach you just about programming and about about computation in general yeah make you feel a little bit smarter yeah that's right that's what we're doing our goal here is to make everybody out there feel a little smarter and a little better about you know software engineering and make you feel good about yourself and challenge you to broaden your horizons. That's right.
那种语言，不仅仅是用它们写代码，而是吸取经验教训，思维方式，并将其应用到我的日常编码中，是的，绝对，似乎每种语言总有一两件事可以教你关于编程和计算的知识，是的，让你感觉自己聪明了一点，是的，没错，这就是我们正在做的，我们的目标是让每个人都感觉聪明一点，对软件工程感觉好一点，让你对自己感觉良好，并挑战你拓宽视野。没错。
That's right. Horizons will be broadened. Whether you like it or not. But hopefully you'll like it. It could be against your will. It's possible that you have this playing in your car stereo and you're engaged in the highway
没错。视野将会拓宽。不管你喜不喜欢。但希望你会喜欢。这可能是违背你的意愿的。有可能你在车里播放这个，你正行驶在高速公路上
and cannot turn it off. So we apologize. We pity you. Pull over now. Yeah, it's not worth it it i know you have to get to work but and if you're still with us despite all of that convincing persuasion that's right so yeah let's talk about the tool of the day all right uh let's see what would my tool of the day be do you have one now i'm just going through my programs here. Are you looking on your computer?
并且无法关掉它。所以我们道歉。我们同情你。现在靠边停车。是的，不值得，我知道你必须去上班，但如果你尽管有所有这些令人信服的劝说，仍然和我们在一起，那是对的，所以是的，让我们谈谈今天的工具，好的，让我们看看我的工具会是什么，你现在有一个吗？我只是在浏览我的程序。你在看你的电脑吗？
I guess I could talk about comics with an X. Comics with an X? Yeah, let's do that. All right. So my tool of the day is comics, C-O-M-I-X. And the way this works is it's a comic book reader. Oh, actually, if you search for comics, you get a bunch of weird... Yeah, it goes under the title GTK Comic Book Viewer.
我想我可以谈谈Comics with an X。Comics with an X？是的，让我们这样做。好的。所以我的工具是Comics，C-O-M-I-X。它的工作方式是一个漫画书阅读器。哦，其实，如果你搜索Comics，你会得到一堆奇怪的……是的，它的标题是GTK Comic Book Viewer。
But basically, the way it works is comics come in this format called CBZ. And they also have another format called CBR. And all it is is just a zip file with a bunch of images in it, or in the CBR case, a RAR file. What this comics does is it opens the zip in memory, it loads all the pictures, and it provides this really slick interface for you to go through the comics. So it'll actually, you can hit spacebar and it'll go from frame to frame, like it kind of intelligently figures out the layout or guesses at the layout of the comic
但基本上，它的工作方式是漫画以这种称为CBZ的格式出现。它们还有另一种称为CBR的格式。它只是一个带有许多图像的zip文件，或者在CBR的情况下，是一个RAR文件。这个Comics所做的是它在内存中打开zip，加载所有图片，并为你提供一个非常流畅的界面来浏览漫画。所以它实际上，你可以按空格键，它会从一帧到另一帧，就像它智能地计算出布局或猜测漫画的布局
and it'll let you navigate through and let you read the comics faster. It does also some sampling and things like that to make them a little sharper, make the images clearer. I use it a lot. I like it. Do you use this mostly on your computer at home or on your phone? Yeah, so I mainly use this on my MacBook when I travel. That's most of the time when I'm reading comics, I'm traveling. And I believe they have a version.
它会让你导航并让你更快地阅读漫画。它还做了一些采样之类的事情，使它们更清晰，使图像更清晰。我经常使用它。我喜欢它。你主要是在家里的电脑上还是在手机上使用这个？是的，所以我主要在旅行时在MacBook上使用它。大多数时候我在阅读漫画时，我都在旅行。我相信他们有一个版本。
If it's not comics, it'll be something else. But they have comic book readers for the iPad and for the iPhone too. So keep in mind if you're a big comic book fan and you subscribe to digital comic books, those CBZ files and Cbr files um can be opened in a ton of different viewers and uh some of them have some really smart capability like this comics one so just keep your eyes out and you can make your comic reading experience a little better nice nice yeah i just never really got into comic book reading growing up i don't know why so oh really but i do on occasion like reading
如果不是Comics，那会是别的。但他们有适用于iPad和iPhone的漫画书阅读器。所以如果你是一个大漫画迷并且订阅了数字漫画书，请记住这一点，那些CBZ文件和CBR文件可以在很多不同的查看器中打开，而且其中一些具有像这个Comics一样非常智能的功能，所以请留意，你可以让你的漫画阅读体验更好，不错，不错，是的，我从小就没怎么迷上阅读漫画，我不知道为什么，所以哦真的吗？但我偶尔喜欢阅读
comic book see i i never got into it until i found out uh like the world beyond superhero comic books you know like i never really got into spider-man i got into x-men a little bit it wasn't really into batman but then i started finding out about you know i guess i'll say more modern ones like the walking Dead and – 300. Yeah. Scrooge McDuck is a comic. It's actually endorsed by Disney, but it's not like a little children's comic. It's actually kind of –
漫画书，看，我直到发现超级英雄漫画书之外的世界才迷上它，你知道，我从来没有真正迷上蜘蛛侠，我迷上了一点X战警，对蝙蝠侠也不是很感兴趣，但后来我开始发现，你知道，我会说更现代的，比如《行尸走肉》和《300》。是的。《史高治叔叔》是一本漫画。它实际上是由迪士尼认可的，但它不像那种小孩子的漫画。它实际上有点——
Really? Yeah. It's kind of like has – I wouldn't say an adult theme because adult has sort of connotations there. But it deals with some kind of mature topics. The humor is sort of high concept it's really surprising for disney um so you're saying is if i read it i wouldn't understand it yeah it's kind of high concept so it's no way of saying you know i don't know i see your nose pointing high into the air sir yeah that's right What are you reading there, sir? Scrooge McDuck. Yeah, only the finest.
真的吗？是的。它有点像有——我不会说成人主题，因为成人有某种含义。但它处理一些成熟的话题。幽默是高概念的，对迪士尼来说真的很令人惊讶，所以你的意思是如果我读了它，我就不会理解它，是的，它有点高概念，所以这不是说你知道，我看到你的鼻子高高地指向空中，先生，是的，没错，你在读什么，先生？史高治叔叔。是的，只有最好的。
I'm sure the Dos Equis guy reads Scrooge McDuck. The most interesting man in the world. Okay, interesting. I'll have to call and ask him. Yeah, maybe we can get him on the show. Oh, there you go. I could see him, you know, I don't drink, but when I do, I like Dos Equis and my Scrooge McDuck comics. It just, it flows.
我相信Dos Equis的那个家伙读史高治叔叔。世界上最有趣的男人。好的，有趣。我得打电话问问他。是的，也许我们可以让他上节目。哦，那太好了。我能看到他，你知道，我不喝酒，但当我喝的时候，我喜欢Dos Equis和我的史高治叔叔漫画。它只是，它很流畅。
You should be a screenwriter. I don't know who would watch your shows, but they'd be funny. So what about you, man? What's your tool of the day? So you and I talked about this a little bit before, but I have my tool of the day just for sheer interestingness of concept, the Bitcoin. Oh, nice. So Bitcoin, the reason part of it, I was just thinking about it again today as I saw that they released a Java version of it. But Bitcoin is a program that you run on your computer that's a peer-to-peer program for doing money transaction. So, you know, eventually it's a new currency based on, I guess, cryptographic principles. I still haven't fully put my head around what it is yet,
你应该成为一名编剧。我不知道谁会看你的节目，但它们会很有趣。那么你呢，伙计？你今天的工具是什么？你和我之前谈过这个，但我今天的工具纯粹是因为概念的有趣性，比特币。哦，不错。所以比特币，原因的一部分，我今天又在想它，因为我看到他们发布了它的Java版本。但比特币是一个你在电脑上运行的程序，是一个用于进行货币交易的点对点程序。所以，你知道，最终它是一种基于，我想，密码学原理的新货币。我仍然没有完全弄清楚它是什么，
but a way of creating a finite supply of things, which if you have a finite supply of things can become money, I guess, or, you know,. And doing transactions, so a way of doing transactions in a peer-to-peer manner that's more easily authenticated in a non-centralized way. And it's a very interesting concept. And so part of the initial thing now is doing the computations to generate these Bitcoins. And if you get this Bitcoin client, not only can you do transactions, you can also be involved in essentially printing money or printing BitMoney. That's pretty cool.
但一种创造有限供应事物的方法，如果你有有限供应的事物，就可以成为货币，我想，或者，你知道。并且进行交易，所以一种以点对点方式进行交易的方法，在非中心化方式下更容易验证。这是一个非常有趣的概念。所以现在最初的事情的一部分是进行计算来生成这些比特币。如果你得到这个比特币客户端，你不仅可以进行交易，你还可以参与本质上印钱或印BitMoney。那很酷。
Yeah. Yeah. The whole, you know, if we look back at currency, you know, in history or whatever, they always look for things that are hard to generate or hard to replace. So like, you know, the Greeks, I believe it was the Greeks or maybe the Romans used salt for currency. That's where salary comes from. Oh, not know that sal salt so salary was your being paid in salt busting out the verbal skills there it's impressive that's it i'm done no more that was the limit oh man that's your one time no so uh so you know they used uh they used salt and then later on you know i mean even to this day gold is used uh you know, they used salt and then later on, you know, I mean, even to this day, gold is used. You know, money used to be actually backed by gold and you could trade it, trade one for the other.
是的。是的。整个，你知道，如果我们回顾货币，你知道，在历史上什么的，他们总是寻找难以生成或难以替代的东西。所以比如，你知道，希腊人，我相信是希腊人或者可能是罗马人使用盐作为货币。这就是“salary”的来源。哦，不知道那个，sal盐，所以salary是你被支付盐，展示语言技能，这令人印象深刻，就是这样，我完了，没有了，那是极限，哦天哪，那是你唯一的一次，不，所以，你知道，他们使用盐，后来，你知道，我的意思是，即使到今天，黄金也被使用，你知道，货币过去实际上是由黄金支持的，你可以交易它，用一个换另一个。
Well, I guess you can still at some level, right? I mean, you can't trade a dollar bill in and get the government to give you gold, but you could trade your dollar bill to somebody in exchange for some amount of gold. Yeah, yeah, definitely. A very, very small sliver of gold at this point. Yeah, that's right or you can trade in your watch to some guy in the in the mall who will give you a small amount of money for it yeah trade in your thirty thousand dollar gold watch and he'll give you twenty bucks for it
好吧，我想你在某种程度上仍然可以，对吧？我的意思是，你不能用一张美元钞票去让政府给你黄金，但你可以用你的美元钞票换取一定数量的黄金。是的，是的，绝对。此时此刻只有非常非常小的一片黄金。是的，没错，或者你可以把你的手表换给商场里的某个人，他会给你一小笔钱，是的，换掉你三万美元的金表，他会给你20块钱
isn't that crazy the we buy gold frenzy that there is out there well i mean i guess the price has gone up so much but the problem is that they're giving you aside from the scamminess of some of the people i mean they're giving you the price for the raw material of gold in the item not the workmanship craftsmanship you know intrinsic or the what is i guess extrinsic value or intrinsic extrinsic value extrinsic yeah yeah so i mean they're not giving you anything for that so the fact that it's a lovely crafted you know gold chain necklace they weigh it see how much gold's in it and that's what they're going to base their payment to you often yeah that's interesting you know because in the commercials that make it seem like all of these necklaces and rings are going to some foundry and getting melted down well in practice they're probably you know just turning
那不是很疯狂吗，外面有“我们买黄金”的狂热，好吧，我的意思是我想价格涨了很多，但问题是，除了某些人的欺诈行为外，他们给你的价格是物品中黄金原材料的价格，而不是工艺、手艺，你知道，内在的，或者什么是，我想是外在价值，还是内在、外在价值，外在，是的，是的，所以我的意思是他们没有给你任何东西，所以事实上它是一条制作精美的金链项链，他们称重看看里面有多少黄金，这就是他们支付给你的基础，是的，这很有趣，你知道，因为在广告中，他们让你觉得所有这些项链和戒指都要去某个铸造厂被熔化，好吧，实际上他们可能，你知道，只是转手
that around and reselling it that's true they probably make more money that way yeah i think people probably feel more comfortable knowing that you know grandma's brooch is getting melted down so then somebody else is going to be wearing it yeah keep the facade going and i think i don't know if it was you or someone else someone was telling me that they actually uh take like the diamonds out like some people will turn in a ring with a diamond in it and they'll just pay them for the gold but then they'll turn around and sell the diamond too oh no that wasn't me that's i i know other you know kind of scams that work like that right you know you go to the flea market or go to some place pawn shop right and you try to pawn something and
转手并转售它，那是真的，他们可能那样赚更多的钱，是的，我想人们可能觉得知道奶奶的胸针被熔化了，然后别人会戴着它，感觉更舒服，是的，保持这种假象，我想，我不知道是你还是别人，有人告诉我他们实际上把钻石取出来，比如有些人会交出一个带钻石的戒指，他们只会为黄金付钱，但随后他们会转手把钻石也卖掉，哦不，那不是我，我知道其他你知道的那种骗局是这样运作的，对吧，你知道你去跳蚤市场或去某个地方当铺，对吧，你试图典当某样东西，
if the guy thinks you don't know what the value of the item is he'll try to you know basically give you as little as possible for it yeah yeah definitely you have a you know original monet picture you know and he says oh this is a print you know i give you 20 bucks for it and he turns around and sells it for 30,000 oh man that is that is pretty shady i have no idea how much art sells for so i think 30,000 that's how much every piece sells for uh that's how much I'd pay for it in modern art. That's right. We should have a board game of the day sometime. Oh, interesting.
如果那个人认为你不知道该物品的价值，他会试图，你知道，基本上给你尽可能少的钱，是的，是的，绝对，你有一张原始的莫奈画，你知道，他说哦这是一张印刷品，你知道我给你20块钱，然后他转手以30,000卖掉，哦天哪，那真是太阴暗了，我不知道艺术品卖多少钱，所以我认为30,000，那是每一件作品卖的价格，那是我会为现代艺术支付的价格。没错。我们应该找个时间玩个当天的棋盘游戏。哦，有趣。
The board game programming language or something. So tell me some more about Bitcoin. So basically, some computers, I guess, are calculating Bitcoins, but there's only so many of them. Eventually, you'll get to the point where no amount of programming will get you the next coin. Right. The pool will be exhausted. And at that point, you will trade services if you want Bitcoin.
棋盘游戏编程语言什么的。所以再多告诉我一些关于比特币的事。所以基本上，一些电脑，我想，正在计算比特币，但它们只有那么多。最终，你会达到一个地步，无论多少编程都无法让你得到下一个硬币。没错。池子将被耗尽。在那时，如果你想要比特币，你将交易服务。
Services are bits or atoms. So it may be, for instance, you want to have web hosting and you could exchange some of the bitcoins that you spent your time on your pc to make for web hosting on somebody else's computer which they can use to turn around and trade for actual dollars to do something else with or whatever i mean at that point it is it's just another currency it's just how many people will actually accept it as payment and as a form of trade. gave Gmail accounts, like some of the first Gmail accounts, to people who participated in a Topcoder Collegiate Challenge back in like 2003 or something like that, when Gmail was brand new. And at the time, people were selling their invites.
服务是比特或原子。所以它可能是，例如，你想要有网络托管，你可以交换一些你花时间在电脑上制作的比特币，用于别人电脑上的网络托管，他们可以用这些比特币转手交易成实际的美元去做别的事情，或者无论什么，我的意思是那时它只是另一种货币，只是有多少人会真正接受它作为支付和贸易形式。给了Gmail账户，比如一些第一批Gmail账户，给那些在2003年左右参加Topcoder Collegiate Challenge的人，当时Gmail是全新的。当时，人们在卖他们的邀请。
Like if you could invite somebody else to Gmail, he would give you a free tour of D.C. It's like they had a whole list of things that you could buy for your Gmail account. Yeah, I i mean anything can become currency i guess it's just how many people will accept it and i guess the idea with bitcoin is that it's a provable finite amount of things and it's because of the peer-to-peer decentralized nature it's very hard to scam or do fraudulent activities on so that math it's kind of a mathematical proof of uh stability i guess so other people
比如如果你能邀请别人加入Gmail，他会给你一次华盛顿特区的免费旅游。就像他们有一整套你可以为你的Gmail账户购买的东西。是的，我的意思是任何东西都可以成为货币，我想这只是有多少人会接受它，我想比特币的想法是它是一种可证明的有限数量的东西，而且由于点对点去中心化的性质，它很难欺诈或进行欺诈活动，所以那个数学，它是一种数学证明，稳定性，我想，所以其他人
should be willing to trust it as opposed to uh regardless of your political beliefs um what the government has decided to do in our country which is just print more money and so kind of breaking the fundamental assumption that you know at a derived level how much money there is by how much things cost and then all of a sudden you know if there's twice how much money there is by how much things cost and then all of a sudden you know if there's twice as much money in the world your money is half as valuable yeah exactly i think there's like oversimplifying to a great extent macroeconomics yeah they must publish right how many bills they print otherwise there'd be no way to you know keep track of inflation right i i it gets beyond my grasp to think about things like that
应该愿意信任它，而不是，无论你的政治信仰如何，政府在我们国家决定做什么，这只是印更多的钱，所以有点打破了基本假设，你知道，在衍生层面，有多少钱取决于东西的价格，然后突然之间，你知道，如果世界上有两倍的钱，你的钱就只有一半的价值，是的，完全正确，我想这在很大程度上过度简化了宏观经济学，是的，他们必须公布，对吧，他们印了多少钞票，否则就没有办法，你知道，跟踪通货膨胀，对吧，我，这超出了我的理解范围，去思考这样的事情
yeah me too it's very interesting i love thinking about it but it's outside of my comfort zone yeah there's like an economic podcast out there where they're explaining everything in detail and uh and we're just making it up so yeah but hey. It sounds good to you. No, that's bad advice. That's bad advice. So, you know, the other thing about this Bitcoin is because it is peer-to-peer and because it's free to sort of, you know, join this network, it could get very popular, which is really important. Yeah. Yeah, I mean, one of the big failings of sort of early civilizations were, you know, each colony had its own. I know in the Roman times, each emperor had their own coin. And so none of them really carried, no pun intended, but carried their weight because they were constantly getting phased out by something else.
是的，我也是，这很有趣，我喜欢思考它，但这超出了我的舒适区，是的，外面有一个经济播客，他们在详细解释一切，而我们只是在编造，所以是的，但嘿。这听起来对你不错。不，那是坏建议。那是坏建议。所以，你知道，关于这个比特币的另一件事是因为它是点对点的，而且因为加入这个网络是免费的，它可能会变得非常流行，这真的很重要。是的，是的，我的意思是，早期文明的一些重大失败是，你知道，每个殖民地都有自己的。我知道在罗马时代，每个皇帝都有自己的硬币。所以它们都没有真正承载，没有双关语的意思，但承载了它们的重量，因为它们不断地被别的东西淘汰。
So it'd be interesting to see if Bitcoin sort of survives the test of time and if it gets popular enough to, you know, hit that critical mass where people will start trading real money for it yeah i got interested in it for a while then kind of just thought it maybe was just a curio curiosity and then i saw it pop up again today and it's kind of like oh i keep hearing this maybe i can get on the ground floor or something awesome yeah it's good stuff all right so so for the programming language of the day, I guess for this first podcast, we decided to talk about C. Yeah, definitely. C is an awesome language. It's a procedural language, which means that it's designed to go kind of one line at a time, as opposed to some of the other languages, like Lisp, which is functional,
所以看看比特币是否经受住了时间的考验，以及它是否变得足够流行，你知道，达到那种人们开始用真钱交易它的临界质量，那会很有趣，是的，我有一段时间对它很感兴趣，然后就觉得它可能只是一个好奇心，然后我今天又看到它冒出来，有点像，哦，我一直听到这个，也许我可以从底层开始什么的，太棒了，是的，这是好东西，好的，所以对于当天的编程语言，我想对于这个第一个播客，我们决定谈谈C。是的，绝对。C是一种很棒的语言。它是一种过程式语言，这意味着它被设计成一行一行地走，而不是像其他一些语言，比如Lisp，它是函数式的，
in which case, you know, you don't necessarily know where you are at any given time. You know, and with C, there's like a very specific main function. And, you know, you're calling other functions and things like that. But it's rather easy to sort of step through a program in C and see what's going on. Right. I guess the other word for that sometimes imperative. Yeah. Yeah, definitely. So I guess it's kind of hard to talk about C because most of my other things are defined
在这种情况下，你知道，你不一定知道你在任何给定时间在哪里。你知道，对于C，有一个非常具体的main函数。而且，你知道，你在调用其他函数之类的。但逐步执行C程序并查看发生了什么相当容易。没错。我想有时另一个词是命令式。是的，是的，绝对。所以我认为谈论C有点难，因为我其他的大部分东西都是定义的
in terms of how they relate to C. So it's like defining the base thing. It's kind of. Yeah. It's like it's like the dictionary definition for the must have the in it. You know, I'm assuming. I don't know. It's just not like the dictionary definition for the must have the in it, you know, I'm assuming. I don't know. It's just not in the dictionary. Yeah, it might not be.
关于它们与 C 的关系。所以这就像是在定义基础事物。某种程度上是这样。是的，这就像是字典里对“必须”这个词的定义，你知道的，我猜。我不知道。它只是不在字典里。是的，可能确实不在。
So C is, interestingly, a lot of C is written in C. And this is something that is a trend that you'll probably find as you listen to the shows is that a lot of languages are written in themselves and what that means is you know they come up with very low level interfaces to the uh you know to the language usually built in a lower level language so for example uh c has functions like open and write which are directly go down to kernel function calls which end up working their way down to assembly. So C is built on these low-level assembly routines. But then also there is like fwrite, which is writing to a file, and fopen, which is opening a file. These functions are written in C. So someone has gone in and written a definition for fopen,
所以有趣的是，C 语言本身很大程度上是用 C 编写的。这是你在收听节目时可能会发现的一个趋势，即许多编程语言都是用它们自己编写的。这意味着，你知道，它们会设计出非常底层的接口，通常是用更底层的语言构建的。例如，C 语言有像 open 和 write 这样的函数，它们直接调用内核函数，最终落实到汇编语言。所以 C 是建立在这些底层汇编例程之上的。但同时也有像 fwrite（写入文件）和 fopen（打开文件）这样的函数。这些函数是用 C 编写的。所以有人已经编写了 fopen 的定义，
which invokes the write kernel calls depending on your OS and things like that. So, I mean, I guess the way that works, you know, is that the first version is written purely in assembly, and then somebody is able to compile C to assembly and do that to a point where you can do everything you would need to do. And then I guess at that point you bootstrapped, and then you can have a compiler entirely in the language which it's compiling. Exactly. That's exactly right.
它会根据你的操作系统等因素调用 write 内核函数。所以，我想它的工作方式是，第一个版本完全用汇编编写，然后有人能够将 C 编译成汇编，并做到这一点，直到你可以完成你需要做的一切。然后我想在那一点上你就完成了引导（bootstrapped），之后你就可以拥有一个完全用它所编译的语言编写的编译器了。没错。完全正确。
So C, you know, the whole or the vast majority of the Linux kernel is written in C, if not the entire thing. Linus Torvalds is a huge C fan. He has this part on his blog where he just is tearing apart C++ and all these other languages. I didn't know that. Yeah, let's see if i can find it here if i find it um that's that's that's interesting yeah i'll send this to you and i'll link it to the forums yeah i mean there's a lot of people i know who um especially in the industry where we're at that claim to write c++ you know and that just means that they have a dot cpp file, but in reality,
所以 C，你知道，整个或绝大多数 Linux 内核都是用 C 编写的，如果不是全部的话。Linus Torvalds 是 C 的超级粉丝。他的博客里有一部分内容专门在抨击 C++ 和所有其他语言。我不知道这一点。是的，看看我能不能在这里找到它，如果我找到了，嗯，那那那很有趣，是的，我会把它发给你，并链接到论坛上。是的，我的意思是，我认识很多人，特别是在我们所处的行业中，他们声称编写 C++，你知道，这仅仅意味着他们有一个 .cpp 文件，但实际上，
they're writing C code. Yeah, yeah, definitely. Which at some level, I mean, C++ and C code are very, very close to each other. And in fact, I mean, you can, it's perfectly valid to write C code in a C++ file. But I guess it's more of the style that we're talking about there, the way you kind of break things down, write classes, those kinds of things. Yeah, so C++, which we'll talk about in another episode, but adds sort of an object-oriented layer on top of C. But in fact, the very first C++ compiler is actually compiled down to C. So the first one written by Strauss-Stru or whatever was, its output was a C file that you then compiled again. So C would be then a very low-level language, right?
他们写的是 C 代码。是的，是的，绝对是。在某种程度上，我的意思是，C++ 和 C 代码非常非常接近。事实上，我的意思是，在一个 C++ 文件中编写 C 代码是完全有效的。但我猜我们在这里讨论的更多是风格问题，你分解事物的方式，编写类的方式，诸如此类。是的，所以 C++，我们会在另一集里讨论，它在 C 之上增加了一个面向对象的层。但事实上，第一个 C++ 编译器实际上是编译成 C 的。所以由 Stroustrup 或其他人编写的第一个版本，它的输出是一个 C 文件，然后你再编译它。所以 C 应该是一种非常底层的语言，对吧？
Yeah, in fact, you can actually type assembly code straight in line with your C code. So you could be writing some C code, you could be saying F open to open this file. And then, you know, load this, load, you know, int I equals zero. All these C things that you're used to seeing. But then all of a sudden you can put ASM, open parenthesis. And now you can put assembly code right there. Bam. Whoa, that's pretty hardcore. Yeah, I know.
是的，事实上，你实际上可以直接在 C 代码中输入汇编代码。所以你可以写一些 C 代码，你可以说 F open 来打开这个文件。然后，你知道，加载这个，加载，你知道，int I 等于零。所有这些你习惯看到的 C 语言的东西。但突然之间，你可以输入 ASM，左括号。现在你可以在那里直接放入汇编代码。砰。哇，那真是太硬核了。是的，我知道。
This is like emerald cooking here, you know. Bam. Bam. There's assembly right there. Yeah, and if you look at the Quake 3 source code, which is, you know, Quake 3 is open source now, you can actually see there's places, especially in the physics routines, where he, you know, there's all this C code. And it gets to the point where he wants to do some math, like, say, figure out gravity's effect on everything in the game. And, you know, for those old processors, it all had to be done in assembly and you'll just see a huge block of
这就像是翡翠烹饪（Emerald Cooking）一样，你知道。砰。砰。汇编代码就在那里。是的，如果你看《雷神之锤 3》（Quake 3）的源代码，你知道，Quake 3 现在是开源的，你实际上可以看到有些地方，特别是在物理例程中，他，你知道，有所有这些 C 代码。当他想要做一些数学运算时，比如，计算重力对游戏中所有事物的影响。而且，你知道，对于那些旧处理器，所有这些都必须用汇编完成，你会看到一大块
assembly code there. Wow. Yeah. I mean, I have done that before once or twice, put some assembly code, but I won't lie, it was for the most part looking up, you know, needing to do this to kind of get the OS into a certain mode or do something kind of finicky. And I pretty much just copy and pasted. Yeah, yeah, definitely. The little bit of assembly I've done has been kind of the same, just looking up on the internet what to do. And I don't know, does anybody really program in assembly nowadays? Yeah, I mean, I did program assembly in college working on DSP-type things or the Motorola 6812 kind of CPUs, the old-school stuff. I mean, you can write in assembly, and it works pretty good. I mean, for something that has really fast interrupts you need to be able to do or a really low-level processor that doesn't have a really good C compiler,
汇编代码在那里。哇。是的。我的意思是，我以前也做过一两次，放入一些汇编代码，但我不会撒谎，大部分情况下是为了查找，你知道，需要这样做来让操作系统进入某种模式或做一些比较棘手的事情。我基本上只是复制粘贴。是的，是的，绝对是。我做过的一点点汇编也差不多，只是在网上查怎么做。而且我不知道，现在还有人真的用汇编编程吗？是的，我的意思是，我在大学里确实用汇编编程，处理 DSP 类型的东西或 Motorola 6812 那种 CPU，老派的东西。我的意思是，你可以用汇编编写，而且效果相当不错。我的意思是，对于某些需要非常快速中断或者没有很好 C 编译器的底层处理器，
or a C compiler that has a lot to be desired, you can get a big advantage writing an assembly. So yeah, there are still people that do it, but it's probably very minute at this point, I would say. Somebody will write in and say that's all they do and prove us wrong. We welcome programming throwdown at gmail.com. That's right. If you use a lot of assembly at work,
或者一个有很多不足之处的 C 编译器，用汇编编写可以获得很大的优势。所以是的，仍然有人这样做，但我认为目前这部分人非常少。有人会写信来说这就是他们所做的一切，并证明我们错了。我们欢迎发送邮件到 programming throwdown at gmail.com。没错。如果你在工作中大量使用汇编，
we'd like to hear from you and hear about kind of your experiences with it and what its applications are nowadays. And actually, I take that back. I did some assembly, but it was SSE. So I was writing SSE code for, did some work on the bullet physics engine so it's an open source physics engine
我们很想听听你的经历，以及它在当今的应用是什么。其实，我收回刚才的话。我确实做过一些汇编，但那是 SSE。所以我当时在为 Bullet 物理引擎编写 SSE 代码，它是一个开源物理引擎。
but again it's basically it was like I just need to loop through these numbers and multiply these two arrays together and so the code ended up not being very complicated yeah interesting yeah I guess people still do it for a lot of things
但同样，它基本上就像是我只需要循环遍历这些数字并将这两个数组相乘，所以代码最终并不复杂。是的，有趣。是的，我想人们仍然在很多事情上这样做。
it's one of the things i guess it just falls out of the mainstream and people kind of forget about it yeah yeah i wonder you know as time goes on if if you know c and c plus plus are going to go sort of the way of assembly it's hard to say yeah i mean because i did sse stuff but i did it in c um they have c i guess bindings for it or i don't know what the right term is there. But you can actually write C code to do SSE. And I have done that before. But it's pretty close to assembly.
这是我猜它只是脱离了主流，人们有点忘记了它。是的，是的，我想知道，随着时间的推移，如果 C 和 C++ 是否会走上汇编的老路。很难说。是的，我的意思是，因为我做过 SSE 的东西，但我是在 C 中做的，嗯，他们有 C 的绑定，我想，或者我不知道那里的正确术语是什么。但你实际上可以编写 C 代码来执行 SSE。我以前做过。但这非常接近汇编。
I mean, it's nothing fancy. It's not much better than just the writing in assembly probably would be. Oh, gotcha. But yeah, other things about C. So I got this link you sent me. Yeah, I guess Linus Torvalds does have a big beef against C++. I know. I would hate to go up against him in a C competition.
我的意思是，这没什么花哨的。它可能并不比直接用汇编编写好多少。哦，明白了。但是的，关于 C 的其他事情。所以我收到了你发给我的这个链接。是的，我想 Linus Torvalds 对 C++ 确实有很大的不满。我知道。我可不想在 C 语言竞赛中与他对抗。
Here you go. C++ is a horrible language. It's made more horrible by the fact that a lot of substandard programmers use it to the point where it's much easier to generate total and utter crap with it. I think that, you know, this with it i think that you know this is a case of um you know i mean linus dorvalds is is extremely gifted right um but he did a lot of his stuff when c++ compilers were terrible and i think that you know that technology has come a really long way i kind of had this this experience with Python where in the beginning
给你。C++ 是一门糟糕的语言。由于许多不合格的程序员使用它，以至于用它生成完全彻底的垃圾变得更容易，这使得它变得更加糟糕。我认为，你知道，这，我认为，你知道，这是一个案例，嗯，你知道，我的意思是 Linus Torvalds 是非常有天赋的，对吧，但他做很多事情的时候，C++ 编译器还很糟糕，而且我认为，你知道，那项技术已经取得了很大的进步。我曾经对 Python 有过这种体验，起初
at Python, let's say 1 or whenever I was looking at it, it was just extremely slow and every line was interpreted. You don't have Psycho, which is a just-in-time compiler for Python. That wasn't around then and all that stuff. So I got really bad taste from all that. It was just extremely slow and it had bugs. I got this bus error. I didn't know what that meant. And it really took going back years later and discovering the language again to get an appreciation for it.
在 Python，比如说 1.0 或我刚开始看它的时候，它非常慢，每一行都是解释执行的。那时还没有 Psycho，也就是 Python 的即时编译器。那时还没有那个东西，所有这些东西都没有。所以我对所有这些留下了非常糟糕的印象。它只是非常慢，而且有 bug。我遇到了总线错误（bus error）。我不知道那意味着什么。这确实需要几年后回去重新发现这门语言，才能对它产生欣赏。
And I think that might be a little bit of what's going on here. Yeah, it's written pretty recently, 2007. So it wasn't that long ago yeah i mean when he wrote it the compilers are definitely in a good state yeah so maybe it is a holder i don't know maybe we'll get him on the show and we'll ask him yeah oh that'd be sweet we can have wishful thinking here in our episode one that that doesn't sound you know we should yeah gotta set our sights high shoot for's right. Shoot for the moon, and if you miss, you'll land upon the stars.
我认为这里可能发生了一点点类似的情况。是的，它是最近写的，2007 年。所以那并没有过去太久。是的，我的意思是，当他写的时候，编译器肯定处于一个良好的状态。所以也许它是一个持有者，我不知道，也许我们会让他上节目，我们会问他。是的，哦，那太棒了。我们可以在我们的第一集中有美好的愿望，那听起来不，你知道我们应该，是的，必须把我们的目标定得很高。没错。瞄准月亮，如果你错过了，你也会落在星星上。
That's right. Swing for the fences. Or if you're being held up in an alley, you swing for the nuts. Did you just use a sports analogy on a programming podcast? Fail. Oh, man. I never played baseball, so. I don't think I've ever even watched baseball.
没错。全力以赴。或者如果你在小巷里被拦住，你就往要害踢。你刚才在编程播客上用了体育类比吗？失败。哦，天哪。我从来没打过棒球，所以。我想我甚至从来没看过棒球。
Really? You've never seen a baseball game? I mean, I saw it on TV once. Oh tv once oh yeah i guess it's just oh yeah oh i'm gonna we're gonna get tons of people let's stop this all right so uh this is interesting um you know glancing over this linus torvalds thing he has a point here that that i've seen some stuff recently about that's kind of interesting where he says that um that he says quite frankly even if the choice of c were to do nothing but keep the C++ programmers out,
真的吗？你从来没看过棒球比赛？我的意思是，我在电视上看过一次。哦，电视上看过一次，哦，是的，我想这只是，哦，是的，哦，我要，我们要收到成千上万的人的来信，让我们停止这个。好吧，所以，嗯，这很有趣，嗯，你知道，浏览一下这个 Linus Torvalds 的东西，他在这里有一个观点，我最近看到了一些东西，这有点意思，他说，嗯，他说坦率地说，即使选择 C 只是为了把 C++ 程序员拒之门外，
that in itself would be a huge reason to use C. And this is kind of interesting. I saw somebody else, who was it? We'll find it later. But somebody was writing and saying that one reason to use new programming languages like Scala or Clojure or some kind of fancy new thing is that if you write your applications in that language and you're a, I guess, small enough, agile enough company to be able to do these kinds of things, that if you write
这本身就是一个使用 C 的巨大理由。这有点意思。我看到别人，是谁来着？我们稍后再找。但有人写道，使用像 Scala 或 Clojure 或某种花哨的新东西这样的新编程语言的一个原因是，如果你用那种语言编写你的应用程序，而且你是一个，我猜，足够小、足够敏捷的公司，能够做这些事情，如果你写
your application in those things, you're going to attract kind of the best programmers because the run-of-the-mill average programmers aren't going to go out there and learn these complicated functional programming languages. So if nothing else, the people who are going to apply to your job openings, who are going to want to work on your projects, are going to be people who are kind of the, you know, cream of the crop, who are out there trying to pursue these interesting and, you know, perhaps game changing ideas. And so if you, you know, kind of similar to Linus's point here, can we call him that? Should we call him Mr. Kornwalds? You know, to his point here that,
你的应用程序用这些东西，你将吸引最好的程序员，因为普通的平均水平的程序员不会去学习这些复杂的函数式编程语言。所以如果没什么别的，那些会申请你的职位空缺，想要在你的项目上工作的人，将是那些，你知道，精英中的精英，他们正在那里试图追求这些有趣的，你知道，也许是改变游戏规则的想法。所以如果你，你知道，有点类似于 Linus 这里的观点，我们可以这样称呼他吗？我们应该叫他 Kornwalds 先生吗？你知道，对于他这里的观点，
you know, it's interesting, you're, you know, kind of the theme of this podcast, choosing your language kind of chooses who's going to be attracted to working on it or working with you. And that has consequences, good and bad at every choice. Yeah. I mean, so, you know, continuing with that, the more programming languages, you know, and that you can sort of put on your resume and, and speak in an educated way about the better you're going to do, because if you find that one guy who, you know, who Ada is his is his love and joy. And if you can talk intelligently about that, you might have an advantage. Yeah. And you had a good point there. Put programming languages on your resume that you
你知道，这很有趣，你，你知道，这个播客的主题，选择你的语言有点选择了谁会被吸引来为它工作或与你一起工作。这有后果，每一个选择都有好有坏。是的。我的意思是，所以，你知道，继续这一点，你能在简历上写出更多的编程语言，并且能以一种受过教育的方式谈论它们，你就越好，因为如果你找到那个，你知道，Ada 是他的挚爱和快乐的人。如果你能明智地谈论它，你可能会有优势。是的。你刚才说得很好。在你的简历上写上编程语言，你
can talk intelligently about. That's a pet peeve of mine. People who put programming languages on their resume and they couldn't even write a hell of a world in that language. Don't do that. No, do not. That makes you look terrible. In general, you don't want to put things on your resume that you're not really good in. Just because if nothing else, let's just say you're this guy and you're just interviewing you. You're on the other side of the desk, and they just randomly pick at something,
可以明智地谈论它们。这是我的一个心病。那些在简历上写了编程语言，却连在那门语言中写一个“Hello World”都做不到的人。别那样做。不，千万别。那让你看起来很糟糕。总的来说，你不想在简历上放你不擅长的东西。仅仅因为如果没什么别的，假设你是这个人，而你只是在面试你。你坐在桌子的另一边，他们只是随机挑选一些东西，
and it happens to be something you don't know, I mean, it's going to be devastating. So you want to make sure that if someone throws a dart at your resume, it's going to land on something that you can speak about. Yep. Yep. It's good stuff. Good stuff. I mean, you got anything more to say about C? There's so much to say that it's almost hard to pick what to talk about. Yeah, so let's talk a little bit about just the sort of different characteristics of C. So C is very low level. It relies heavily on the compiler. So C doesn't have its own memory management. It doesn't have like a garbage collection or anything like that.
而恰好是你不知道的东西，我的意思是，这将是毁灭性的。所以你要确保如果有人向你的简历投掷飞镖，它会落在你可以谈论的东西上。是的。是的。好东西。好东西。我的意思是，关于 C 你还有什么要说的吗？有太多要说的了，几乎很难选择谈论什么。是的，所以让我们谈谈 C 的一些不同特性。所以 C 是非常底层的。它严重依赖编译器。所以 C 没有自己的内存管理。它没有像垃圾回收之类的东西。
You have to do all the mallocs and frees yourself. And that's a pro and a con. Yeah, it's a pro in the sense that, you know, if you program something, you have a good idea of how much time and how much memory it's going to take. It can also be very consistent. You know, you can allocate your memory up front versus something like if you've used MATLAB or Python. Every time you do an operation, you might be allocating more memory. And that very next operation might be the one that allocates so much memory that your computer has to sort of reorganize. And that could take a very long time.
你必须自己完成所有的 malloc 和 free。这是一个优点也是一个缺点。是的，这是一个优点，因为，你知道，如果你编写了什么东西，你对它需要多少时间和多少内存有一个很好的了解。它也可以非常一致。你知道，你可以预先分配你的内存，而不是像如果你使用 MATLAB 或 Python 那样。每次你执行一个操作，你可能都在分配更多的内存。而紧接着的那个操作可能就是那个分配了太多内存，导致你的计算机不得不进行某种重组的操作。那可能需要很长时间。
In C, C puts you in the driver's seat. So you know when you're allocating and deallocating memory. You know when you're going to take a performance hit for doing something. You know, you can watch your buffers, and if they start to get too full, you could decide when to, you know,
在 C 中，C 把你放在驾驶座上。所以你知道你什么时候在分配和释放内存。你知道你什么时候会因为做某事而受到性能影响。你知道，你可以观察你的缓冲区，如果它们开始变得太满，你可以决定什么时候，你知道，
make them larger, et cetera. C really leaves you in your own hands there. Yeah, I mean, I guess other languages try to address that, right? I mean, in Python, you can do stuff to try to make it allocate in advance, but ultimately that's not the way it's intended to be used. And C is kind of the default way is to make it be used that way. Yeah, yeah, definitely. But a lot of people mess it up.
把它们变大，等等。 C 真的让你自己掌握。是的，我的意思是，我想其他语言试图解决这个问题，对吧？我的意思是，在 Python 中，你可以做一些事情来尝试让它提前分配，但最终那不是它预期的使用方式。而 C 的默认方式就是让它那样使用。是的，是的，绝对是。但很多人搞砸了。
A lot of people forget to free stuff or try to dereference bad pointers. And they get tripped up in managing their memory correctly. And that's a dangerous thing because it can make your program crash. Yeah, definitely. And yeah, the other thing, C does not give you a safety net. So in Java, if you have some array that's 10 elements and you try and access the 11th one, Java has a virtual machine. So Java has a sort of like a computer inside a computer. And we'll talk about this more later.
很多人忘记释放东西或试图解引用错误的指针。他们被正确管理内存绊倒了。这是一件危险的事情，因为它会导致你的程序崩溃。是的，绝对是。而且是的，另一件事，C 不给你安全网。所以用 Java，如果你有一个 10 个元素的数组，而你试图访问第 11 个，Java 有一个虚拟机。所以 Java 有一种像计算机里的计算机。我们稍后会更多地讨论这个。
But, you know, the simulated computer on the inside will fail and will throw an error back. In C, you're talking straight to your hardware. So you're talking straight to your memory. So you're talking straight to your memory, to the processor, to any disks you have. And if you have an array of size 12 and you go for the 14th element, it's just going to pick whatever is there in that memory and return it. It'll probably be some crazy number. If you're expecting in between 1 and 100, you might get 2 million. But it will let you do that. The real danger isn't that, though. That is dangerous.
但是，你知道，里面的模拟计算机将会失败并抛出一个错误。在 C 中，你是在直接与你的硬件对话。所以你是在直接与你的内存对话。所以你是在直接与你的内存、处理器、你拥有的任何磁盘对话。如果你有一个大小为 12 的数组，而你去寻找第 14 个元素，它只会挑选内存中在那里的任何东西并返回它。那可能是一个疯狂的数字。如果你期望在 1 到 100 之间，你可能会得到 200 万。但它会让你这样做。不过，真正的危险不是那个。那确实很危险。
The danger is when it works most of the time, but then the critical moment you're demoing for your boss or, worse, the customer. All of a sudden, that's the time that the way it's allocated happens to be that that memory is being used for something else. Or it's used by the operating system or something and it's instead of returning the value you've expected every other time like let's say zero now it does return something different because you it isn't what you thought it was yeah yeah definitely and you know these problems they start to show up um in production so for example uh let's say you have an array of 10,000 for your, let's say you're Amazon and you're categorizing books in C. And you gave space for, you know, let's say a million books. But now you roll this out to the production environment and you surpass a million books or a million comments on books.
危险在于它大部分时间都能工作，但在你为老板演示的关键时刻，或者更糟的是，为客户演示时。突然之间，那次分配的方式恰好是那块内存被用于其他事情。或者它被操作系统使用，或者其他什么，它没有返回你每次都期望的值，比如零，现在它确实返回了不同的东西，因为你，它不是你认为的那样。是的，是的，绝对是。而且你知道，这些问题开始出现在生产环境中，嗯，例如，嗯，假设你有一个 10,000 的数组，用于你的，假设你是亚马逊，你正在用 C 对书籍进行分类。你给了空间，你知道，假设是一百万本书。但现在你把这个推向生产环境，你超过了一百万本书或一百万条关于书的评论。
Now you've overridden that array and who knows what's going to happen when you go back to your simulated environment you're never going to find that error because it depends on something that you can only experience in large volume also points out the importance of testing yeah definitely so we should actually maybe the next show
现在你已经覆盖了那个数组，谁知道当你回到你的模拟环境时会发生什么，你永远不会发现那个错误，因为它取决于你只能在大容量中体验到的东西。这也指出了测试的重要性。是的，绝对是。所以我们实际上也许下一集
our goal is to kind of do like a little explanation of language and on the next show kind of do a little recap. Maybe in the recap and kind of tool section, we'll talk about Valgrind and some of those other tools that you can use. Yeah, yeah. So, I mean, we probably should, you know, maybe we should have done this before. But, you know, probably should come up with kind of a format for everything. Like I was thinking about, we should also talk about libraries. So, for instance, C, you know, libraries, a lot of people kind of call c well later programming languages kind of poke fun
我们的目标是做一个语言的小解释，在下一集做一个小回顾。也许在回顾和工具部分，我们会谈论 Valgrind 和一些你可以使用的其他工具。是的，是的。所以，我的意思是，我们可能应该，你知道，也许我们应该早点这样做。但是，你知道，可能应该为所有事情想出一个格式。就像我在想的，我们也应该谈论库。所以，例如，C，你知道，库，很多人称 C，嗯，后来的编程语言有点取笑
at c by saying these languages are batteries included that's a python saying i guess right that you know it comes with all of the other stuff you might need versus c doesn't um but there are a lot of libraries you can pull from that give you a lot of powerful tools in C, and especially, I guess, C++. But a lot of libraries out there that give you functionality or reusability and help you build up that code base a lot faster than if you had to do everything from scratch. So it has good library support, I would say. Yeah, definitely. support I would say yeah definitely CNC plus plus it seems like every every you know program out there either has a C C++ version or or is solely C C++ and then has bindings for everything else but those aren't always straightforward
C，说这些语言是“电池包含”（batteries included），这是一个 Python 的说法，我猜，对吧，它自带了你可能需要的所有其他东西，而 C 没有。但有很多库你可以从中提取，它们在 C 中为你提供了很多强大的工具，特别是，我猜，C++。但有很多库可以为你提供功能或可重用性，并帮助你比从头开始做所有事情更快地构建代码库。所以我认为它有很好的库支持。是的，绝对是。支持，我会说。是的，绝对是。C 和 C++，看起来每个，每个，你知道，现有的程序要么有一个 C/C++ 版本，要么完全是 C/C++，然后有其他所有东西的绑定，但那些并不总是直接的。
I mean having used a number of libraries they can range in difficulty from very easy to integrate to next impossible to get working in your program yeah definitely not a lot of consistency on that front no and yeah that's actually a very easy to integrate to next to impossible to get working in your program. Yeah, definitely. So not a lot of consistency on that front. No, and yeah, that's actually a good point. So let's talk a little bit about the different C standards. I don't know a lot about the history of it, but at this point right now, there's basically two C standards.
我的意思是，使用过许多库，它们的难度范围从非常容易集成到几乎不可能在你的程序中工作。是的，绝对是，在这方面没有太多的一致性。不，而且是的，这实际上是一个非常容易集成到几乎不可能在你的程序中工作。是的，绝对是。所以在这方面没有太多的一致性。不，而且是的，这实际上是一个很好的观点。所以让我们谈谈不同的 C 标准。我对它的历史了解不多，但目前为止，基本上有两个 C 标准。
There's the, I guess we'll call it the microsoft c standard and then there's the uh was it c99 well there's ncc and then c99 oh okay yeah i'm calling that the microsoft one since they're the only ones that really like you know stick to that one but um but yeah there's so for example to ncc no no no no no ncc, I mean, that's what like GCC complied to, right? Before now like C99 coming out, right? I mean, Microsoft kind of invented their own subset of ANT-CC that they complied
有，我猜我们称之为微软 C 标准，然后有，嗯，是 C99 吗？好吧，有 ANSI C，然后是 C99。哦，好的，是的，我称之为微软那个，因为他们是唯一真正喜欢，你知道，坚持那个的人，但，嗯，但是的，有，所以例如 ANSI C，不，不，不，不，ANSI C，我的意思是，那是 GCC 编译的东西，对吧？在现在像 C99 出来之前，对吧？我的意思是，微软有点发明了他们自己的 ANSI C 子集，他们遵守
with. And then they've gotten better over time to now they're actually pretty compliant in my understanding. Oh, maybe I'm thinking Oh, yeah, I'm thinking of ANT-CC I think. That's what I was talking about. Alright, so keep going. Go to your original point anyways. Well, let me, I'm looking it up right now. Okay, so then there was C99,
那个。然后随着时间的推移，他们变得更好了，现在据我了解，他们实际上相当合规。哦，也许我在想，哦，是的，我在想 ANSI C，我想。那是我刚才说的。好吧，所以继续。无论如何，回到你最初的观点。好吧，让我，我正在查它。好的，那么有 C99，
which, I mean, didn't change anything drastic, right? I mean, it just kind of added support for some new data types and bigger numbers, that kind of stuff. Yeah, let me, all right. The other thing that if you hear people talking about C, there are a lot of bad things you can do in C. C gives you a lot of power, but with great power comes great responsibility.
这，我的意思是，没有改变任何剧烈的东西，对吧？我的意思是，它只是增加了一些对新数据类型和更大数字的支持，诸如此类。是的，让我，好吧。如果你听到人们谈论 C，还有另一件事，在 C 中你可以做很多坏事。C 给了你很多权力，但能力越大，责任越大。
That's right. And so, you know, they'll do things, they give you like macros, they give you all sorts of ability to, you know, have pointers to functions and, you know, have lists to functions and, you know, have lists of functions that you can call and change with what function does when. And I mean, it gives you all sorts of, you know, we say crazy things, but in some cases, those are really necessary to
没错。所以，你知道，他们会做一些事情，他们给你像宏，他们给你各种能力，你知道，有指向函数的指针，你知道，有函数列表，你知道，有你可以调用并改变函数功能的函数列表。而且我的意思是，它给了你各种，你知道，我们说疯狂的事情，但在某些情况下，那些对于
be able to do those kind of nonstandard, unexpected, hard to wrap your brain around functions. But in other cases, they can be used for, you know, obfuscation or not that any of us would ever do this, but showing off. And so people will try to show off by using what are those called the tertiary operators, you know, questions. And, you know, if you've ever seen the obfuscated C contest, people can write, you know, just completely unreadable c source code that's completely valid complies with the standards and compiles and is fast um but you could never read it yeah it's much less change it uh so here's what i was thinking okay yeah back there is and yeah it's fine there's ncc and then there's c99 which is i guess the newer one and so microsoft Visual Studio doesn't support C99. It only supports the NCC. And this is a problem because like FFmpeg, for example,
能够做那些非标准的、意想不到的、难以理解的函数确实是必要的。但在其他情况下，它们可以被用于，你知道，混淆，或者不是说我们中的任何人会这样做，但炫耀。所以人们会试图通过使用那些所谓的“三元运算符”来炫耀，你知道，问号。而且，你知道，如果你曾经看过“混淆 C 大赛”（Obfuscated C Contest），人们可以编写，你知道，完全不可读的 C 源代码，它是完全有效的，符合标准，并且编译且速度快，嗯，但你永远读不懂它。是的，它更难改变。嗯，这是我在想的，好的，是的，在那后面，是的，没关系，有 ANSI C，然后有 C99，我猜是较新的那个，所以微软 Visual Studio 不支持 C99。它只支持 ANSI C。这是一个问题，因为像 FFmpeg，例如，
which is a video streaming library, is written in C99. So to use it in Visual Studio, you'd have to just go through and hack the entire code base. And everywhere where you see something that isn't compliant, you have to go in and fix it. Yeah, it'd be massive. So there are two different standards. And the hope is that all of the compilers will start to get to the point
它是一个视频流库，是用 C99 编写的。所以要在 Visual Studio 中使用它，你必须通读并破解整个代码库。而且在你看到任何不合规的地方，你都必须进去修复它。是的，那将是巨大的。所以有两个不同的标准。希望所有的编译器都能开始达到
where they're supporting C99. Yeah, the cross-compiler, cross-platform, and C, C++, because are you know compiling right down to machine code it's a pro and a con but you know the con is that you got to be very careful about what you're doing because the way one thing works on one platform could be completely different from the way it works on another yeah let's talk about that a little bit so the difference between C and C++ from other languages like Python or Java is that, as we talked about earlier, they're talking directly to the machine. And more specifically, they're talking directly to the operating system.
它们支持 C99 的地步。是的，交叉编译器，跨平台，以及 C，C++，因为你是，你知道，直接编译成机器码，这是一个优点也是一个缺点，但，你知道，缺点是你必须非常小心你在做什么，因为一件事在一个平台上工作的方式可能与它在另一个平台上工作的方式完全不同。是的，让我们谈谈那个。所以 C 和 C++ 与 Python 或 Java 等其他语言的区别在于，正如我们之前讨论的那样，它们是在直接与机器对话。更具体地说，它们是在直接与操作系统对话。
So you have to use a compiler specific to your type of hardware and to your OS. So in the case of Windows, you have some choices. You can use Visual C++, which is a Microsoft product. You could use GCC for Windows. It's called MingGW, which is a minimalist GNU for Windows,
所以你必须使用特定于你的硬件类型和操作系统的编译器。所以在 Windows 的情况下，你有一些选择。你可以使用 Visual C++，这是一个微软产品。你可以使用 Windows 的 GCC。它叫 MingGW，也就是 Minimalist GNU for Windows，
is what MingGW stands for. You can also use Intel. They have a compiler. On the Linux side... there's a couple of others too right uh less popular now but there's the um borland have one for a while right oh yeah that's right yeah okay but sorry go ahead not to interrupt you oh no it's cool i threw you off here i'm pulling up no no it's cool i'm pulling up c compilers right now yeah on wikipedia you'll see there's a ton of them turbo c you remember that back of the day all right so well now on Linux oh yeah on Linux
这就是 MingGW 的含义。你也可以使用 Intel。他们有一个编译器。在 Linux 侧……还有几个其他的，对吧？嗯，现在不太流行了，但有，嗯，Borland 有一段时间有一个，对吧？哦，是的，没错，是的，好的，但抱歉，你继续，不是要打断你。哦，不，没关系，我让你分心了，我正在拉起，不，不，没关系，我正在拉起 C 编译器，现在，是的，在维基百科上你会看到有一大堆，Turbo C，你还记得那个吗，在过去的日子里。好吧，所以现在在 Linux 上，哦，是的，在 Linux 上
there is um you know GCC is the heavy hitter on Linux you know just about everything is going to be built in that ICC which is the Intel compiler our Intel C compiler that that's also on Linux but oh so the point of this is the programs that you create with C or C++ will be specific to that operating system and that hardware so you know in Java for example you can create a dot class file which is you know your your compiled source code and run that on any machine. So I can compile some Java code on my machine and then go to another Linux machine or go to an ARM machine or go anywhere and run that code, and it'll run just fine.
有，嗯，你知道，GCC 是 Linux 上的重头戏，你知道，几乎所有东西都是用那个构建的。ICC，也就是 Intel 编译器，我们的 Intel C 编译器，那也在 Linux 上，但，哦，所以这个的重点是，你用 C 或 C++ 创建的程序将特定于那个操作系统和那个硬件。所以，你知道，在 Java 中，例如，你可以创建一个 .class 文件，也就是，你知道，你的编译后的源代码，并在任何机器上运行它。所以我可以在我的机器上编译一些 Java 代码，然后去另一台 Linux 机器，或者去一台 ARM 机器，或者去任何地方运行那段代码，它会运行得很好。
If you build an executable in C and then take it over to your Mac and try and run it, you're going to be in trouble. It's not going to know what to do with that. You can do cross-compilation, though, right? I mean, on a Windows machine, you could tell your compiler to compile it for a Macintosh. Yeah, definitely. That's a good point. So you can do that, but whichever you decide, it's going to be set to that.
如果你在 C 中构建了一个可执行文件，然后把它带到你的 Mac 上并尝试运行它，你会有麻烦。它不知道该怎么处理那个。不过，你可以进行交叉编译，对吧？我的意思是，在 Windows 机器上，你可以告诉你的编译器为 Macintosh 编译它。是的，绝对是。这是一个很好的观点。所以你可以这样做，但无论你决定哪一个，它都将设置为那个。
So you can't compile something that will work on several different architectures. And the other thing to point out, I mean, I guess to us, we kind of forget about it, but you don't have to have an operating system to be able to use C. I mean, there are many people writing, the operating system itself is written in C or C++ for the most part. I mean, there are exceptions,
所以你不能编译出能在几个不同架构上工作的东西。而且要指出的另一件事，我的意思是，我想对我们来说，我们有点忘记了，但你不必拥有操作系统就能使用 C。我的意思是，有很多人在编写，操作系统本身在很大程度上是用 C 或 C++ 编写的。我的意思是，有例外，
but most of the serious ones, like you pointed out earlier, Linux, I mean, Windows is written in C, C++. So the operating system itself is written in those languages because it doesn't presume that there's an operating system running. I mean, it can. So if you write code compiled for Windows to do GUI stuff, for instance, it's going to assume there's an operating system there.
但大多数严肃的，像你之前指出的，Linux，我的意思是，Windows 是用 C、C++ 编写的。所以操作系统本身是用这些语言编写的，因为它不假设有一个操作系统在运行。我的意思是，它可以。所以如果你编写为 Windows 编译的代码来做 GUI 东西，例如，它会假设那里有一个操作系统。
But there's other ways to write it where those assumptions aren't necessary and that you can have code that runs without an operating system yeah yeah definitely and so if you're wondering why this is you know why in java and python um you can write your code and you can create the pyc files in python or the class files in java and and just send those around across the internet and just know that they'll work on the other person's machine that's because those people it's like guido in the case of python or uh do you know who made java oh i should here let's look it up don't put me on the spot you're making you're ruining our street cred uh history i guess james gosling gosling james gosling mike sheridan and patrick and there's a couple guys there who are kind of famous and have gone on to work on other languages as well I guess James Gosling, Mike Sheridan, and Patrick...
但还有其他编写方式，那些假设是不必要的，你可以拥有在没有操作系统的情况下运行的代码。是的，是的，绝对是。所以如果你想知道为什么这是，你知道，为什么在 Java 和 Python 中，嗯，你可以编写你的代码，你可以创建 Python 中的 pyc 文件或 Java 中的 class 文件，并只是在互联网上传送那些东西，并知道它们会在对方的机器上工作，那是因为那些人，就像 Python 的 Guido，或者，你知道是谁制作了 Java 吗？哦，我应该，让我们查一下，别让我当场出丑，你正在毁掉我们的街头信誉，历史，我猜 James Gosling，Gosling，James Gosling，Mike Sheridan 和 Patrick，还有几个家伙在那里，他们有点出名，并且也继续从事其他语言的工作。我猜 James Gosling，Mike Sheridan 和 Patrick……
I mean, there's a couple of guys there who are kind of famous and have gone on to work on other languages as well. But I'm not as up on that history as I should be. You were supposed to tell me we're going to talk about this before. So I could sound smart. We'll cut all this out. Actually, we'll say we'll cut it out and we won't. Yeah, just kidding. I'm lazy. So these people have gone to painstaking time and effort into making sure that when you do, you know,
我的意思是，有几个家伙在那里，他们有点出名，并且也继续从事其他语言的工作。但我对那段历史的了解不如我应该的那样。你本应该告诉我我们要谈论这个的。所以我可以听起来很聪明。我们会把所有这些都剪掉。其实，我们会说我们会把它剪掉，但我们不会。是的，开个玩笑。我很懒。所以这些人已经花费了艰苦的时间和努力，确保当你做，你知道，
0.5 plus 0.5 in Python, that it's going to give you 1.0 on every single machine. Or when you, you know, create an array, when you create a string, or when you try to access a GUI, when you try to access a gui when you try and create a a gui that it um that it works the same or or as close to the same as it can in every os that's one of the nice things about java is you can make a gui and and just know that it'll work
0.5 加 0.5 在 Python 中，它会在每一台机器上给你 1.0。或者当你，你知道，创建一个数组，当你创建一个字符串，或者当你尝试访问 GUI，当你尝试访问 GUI，当你尝试创建一个 GUI 时，它，嗯，它在每个操作系统中工作得一样，或者尽可能地一样。这是 Java 的好处之一，你可以制作一个 GUI，并且知道它会在
on every computer you know with c and c plus plus you're typically coding for your hardware and your OS. True, true. Yeah. There are some libraries that can sort of make things cross-platform. And maybe we should talk about some of those. Yeah, we'll have to get to those. Definitely, definitely. Yeah. So much to talk about, so little time.
每台计算机上工作。你知道，用 C 和 C++，你通常是在为你的硬件和操作系统编码。真的，真的。有一些库可以使事情跨平台。也许我们应该谈谈其中的一些。是的，我们必须谈到那些。绝对，绝对。是的。有太多要谈的了，时间太少了。
Yeah. I don't know of any C ones. I use mostly C++ ones. But I guess I'll mention a couple. Agar is a C library for um for guis that is cross-platform what does that use uh like open gl on the back end or right do you know yeah it so it actually has several different back ends um but i think open gl is one of them okay um do you know any like you want to throw in one or two C libraries?
是的。我不知道任何 C 的库。我主要使用 C++ 的。但我猜我会提到几个。Agar 是一个用于 GUI 的 C 库，它是跨平台的。那个使用什么，嗯，像后端的 OpenGL，或者对吗？你知道吗？是的，它实际上有几个不同的后端，但我认为 OpenGL 是其中之一。好的，嗯，你知道任何像你想加入的一两个 C 库吗？
See, I'm going to say something and it's going to be C++ and then we're going to feel kind of bad. Yeah, it's so hard, right? Because it's hard to know. I mean, a lot of the stuff I do for like low-level timing, doing analysis on my code and profiling type stuff, most of those are, you know, just c just for the sake of they don't need to be c++ and that keeps them more compatible yeah yeah definitely there's a number of platform specific libraries that are c for for instance if you do coding on the ti dsps ti has a set of fixed point libraries that are in c oh true because some of their dsps don't have floating point support or the floating point support is large or slow and or slow yeah yeah another one is uh expat which is a xml parsing
看，我要说一些东西，它会是 C++ 的，然后我们会感觉有点糟糕。是的，这太难了，对吧？因为很难知道。我的意思是，我做的很多事情，比如底层计时，对我的代码进行分析和分析类型的东西，大多数都是，你知道，只是 C，仅仅因为它们不需要是 C++，这使它们更兼容。是的，是的，绝对是。有许多特定于平台的库是 C 的，例如，如果你在 TI DSP 上进行编码，TI 有一套用 C 编写的定点库。哦，真的，因为他们的一些 DSP 没有浮点支持，或者浮点支持很大或很慢，或者很慢。是的，是的，另一个是 Expat，它是一个 XML 解析
library are you just continuing to show me up by telling me how many you can name and i can't name yeah this is like name that i guess well was there a game show like that where it's like yet to keep going we should invent one yeah we'll invent our own game show like that where it's like you have to keep going? We should invent one. Yeah, we'll invent our own game show. We'll write it in C. How about that? And then we'll win. That's right.
库。你是在继续通过告诉我你能命名多少而我不能命名来炫耀吗？是的，这就像是“命名那个”，我猜，好吧，有没有像那样的游戏节目，就像你必须继续？我们应该发明一个。是的，我们会发明我们自己的游戏节目。我们会用 C 编写它。那怎么样？然后我们会赢。没错。
And we'll have a memory overrun. Oh, and that's something else we should point out, the security. There's a number of security problems with C and C++. Not inherent, but if you're not careful, for instance you take input from uh from the command line somebody could give you a just absolutely gigantic uh string and cause a uh i guess at that point a buffer overflow yep so we don't we don't have time to get into that right now but yeah we can do a whole show on on all that stuff but yeah i mean if you you know you're reading the news as we talked about the beginning of the show that guy who hacked the ps3 and whatever and a lot of these hacks these hardware
而且我们会有一个内存溢出。哦，那是我们应该指出的另一件事，安全性。C 和 C++ 有许多安全问题。不是固有的，但如果你不小心，例如你从命令行获取输入，有人可以给你一个绝对巨大的字符串，并导致一个，我猜在那一点上是一个缓冲区溢出。是的，所以我们没有时间现在深入讨论那个，但是的，我们可以做一个关于所有这些东西的完整节目，但是的，我的意思是，如果你，你知道，你正在阅读新闻，正如我们在节目开始时谈到的，那个黑了 PS3 的家伙，无论什么，以及许多这些硬件
hacks what they're doing is c is such a low level that they're going in and adding electricity to the traces running between two chips causing numbers to be bigger than they should be and they're just waiting for someone for for a flaw in the c program and for them to be able to get access to some block of memory that was generally restricted. This is good stuff. So, you know, I think call it here for our first episode.
黑客，他们正在做的是，C 是如此底层，以至于他们进去并向运行在两个芯片之间的走线添加电力，导致数字比它们应该的大，他们只是在等待某人，为了 C 程序中的一个缺陷，并让他们能够获得对某些通常受限制的内存块的访问。这是好东西。所以，你知道，我想在这里结束我们的第一集。
It's been pretty good, Jason. Yeah, I think this has been great. I've had a lot of fun. All right. Well, that's it for today. See you guys in two weeks. Yeah, definitely. See you guys later.
这很不错，Jason。是的，我认为这很棒。我玩得很开心。好吧，今天就到这里。两周后见。是的，绝对是。大家稍后见。
Hope you have fun programming and see go out and learn something new programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I, and share alike in kind. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
希望你玩得开心编程，去学习一些新东西。Programming Throwdown 是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，以重新混合、改编作品，但你必须提供对 Patrick 和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。